in the new year to come invest in taking
care of your body
invest in nurturing and nourishing your
relationships you will have to make one
choice you're not going to be spared by
life you will always have to make one
choice and if I think I don't change I
don't keep up with the times
well I'm outdated if you're not updated
you are outdated leave motivation watch
a top 10 with believe nation what's up
believe nation it's Evan I believe in
you and this channel is designed to be a
part of your daily success routine so
let's get your motivation to attend and
get you believing in you grab a snack
and join today's lessons from a man who
went from being an electrical engineer
for hewlett-packard to becoming a monk
and a life coach teaching people the
importance of conscious leadership
happiness and coping with stress
he's guru Gopal das and here's my take
on his top 50 rules for success
we knew something in the game of life
you're playing a cricket match against
an entity called the mind no one on
planet earth can stop you from
accomplishing in achieving what you want
if you can bat against the googly z'
that the mind pulls at you
how many of you have experienced that
the mild balls googlies
[Music]
good when it comes to exercising and
jogging how many of you know that the
mind bulls boobies much ah so ja how
many of you have trouble in studying as
students and you come here you hear all
of these things don't get distracted by
whatsapp don't get distracted by
internet pornography don't get
distracted by Twitter don't get
distracted by Facebook study don't get
distracted by birds to do bird-watching
study all these distractions is the
rocket which updates later gulosa do
look up to people okay so one father was
telling his son deck Dexter a classmate
Lucy and a Lucy maybe they first by you
or to Malik Beluga Oh Bella dig they
came Hey look
[Applause]
I'll tell you something my god why
because the mind doesn't want you to win
the game of life how many of you wanted
to wake up early in the morning reasons
only one did I asked wanted to wake up
early in the morning and how many of you
have done something called as setting an
alarm clock and then after setting the
alarm clock that's an alarm you want it
or not it rings and when it rings the
mind puts its first googly what does the
mind by putting the googly makes you
clean bowled when you do the first snows
you are out
you are out if you snooze you are out I
want to say one thing just one and
probably this will change the direction
of your life you know something when you
snooze the Allah what happens you decide
to give in to the mind spot
and this is how your morning begins by
giving into the mind
sabira Quichua to PA his wall as a clean
bold hoga kam and dipping it into the
Misurata by giving him and it's no
problem giving in sleeping five minutes
extra is no problem the problem is you
develop the attitude of giving in you
tell yourself that what I decided last
night is not as important what is
important is what the mind says because
we listen I'll tell you something my
humble advice because it's not just
about getting up in the morning it's
about every aspect of life whether it's
your work if you're working whether it's
your study if you study whatever we do
the problem is it's not about one thing
Saverio gana it reflects in every area
of life is limited Oh average Harbhajan
animal uma hipness an iota
Jarvis column la Vella can char be
scooped or don't allow that smooth rule
number two learn how to respond there is
a concept called sledging in cricket
where the opponent team comes and gives
Godley to the frenchman Godley they try
to distract them and take their focus
away
one thing that Sachin is are told for in
the history of cricket is sledging
hasn't bothered him this man is cool are
you cool when people do sledging against
you in the game of life are you cool or
you lose your cool there will always be
people who are out of control can you
stop a guy from criticizing you can you
start an opponent team from sledging
puts on a curse acting it's called
things which are out of our control
people are out of our control sometimes
our situations in your control many
times no
the guy who was batting was expecting an
in swing ball and that's what the bowler
bold and one gush of wind an in swing
becomes an outswing and is caught out
a lot of things situations people are
just out of our control how many of you
think question paper is in your control
and when things go wild nah I'll tell
you what happens with us this what
happens with us you know we react
stimulus off a person sledging against
us criticizing pulling us down envious
of us conspiring politicking makes us
react and form out I throw ever be start
reacting also and look at this this is
also sealed
[Music]
the question is do you want to be a 7-up
kin or oxy cool bottle of water and I'm
sure a lot of us would say spur boozy he
looks tiny hippo G and thus in our life
we will always have a stimulus and we
can choose to respond because between
the stimulus and response is our choice
a great personality is not born in the
maternity ward a great personality is
born by the choices that one makes and
therefore when there are all kinds of
stimuli we have to learn how to respond
if we are not strong spiritually it is
impossible if we are not strong
culturally it is impossible all this
sounds great and good and we know yes
but I want to do it I can't be a can of
soda I want to be a water bottle but is
it so easy no that is why coming here is
so important that is why this
foundational ethics of spirituality are
so crucial in this age as all of you are
going to be successful in your own areas
of life if not cricket per se and thus
we have to learn how to respond rule
number three don't lead the life of I
what is the most selfish one lettered
word
i-isn't everything revolves around I I
phone iPad iPod and the man says I paid
everything revolves around the eye and
what does I stand for i stands for
expectations i should be treated like
this i should be loved like this i
should be dealt with like this i should
be respected like this i should be given
these mini marks i should not be given
this at all leading a life of super high
expectations everything revolves around
my opinions my desires my likes my
dislikes I love this I want this I don't
want this
ai ai ai ai ai you think life will be a
very happy life when it revolves around
AI from a childhood we have grown up
like this you only learn to take and
everyone has to fulfill my expectations
everything has to be up to my
expectations therefore when people come
to God people come to Temple also
they're only asking give me what I want
no one comes to say I love you I won't I
want to give you when the president of
the United States John F Kennedy came up
to stage for his first presidential
speech his voice rumbled into the public
addresses too many said ask not what the
country can do for you ask what you can
do for the country and so we are saying
ask not what God can do for you ask what
you can do forgot but no one asks that
because the eye is so big my
expectations my desires my things are so
powerful that even when I come to a
temple and ring a bell all I'm doing is
asking
the more we lead a life of I are I will
always be frustrated because people
don't exist in this world to just
fulfill your expectations therefore
ladies and gentlemen the most selfish
one lettered word is AI which stands for
expectations and therefore avoid this
word how do you avoid this word be
realistic in your expectations a big
shocker anime problem knee but
understand that not everyone will
fulfill your expectation and secondly
avoid this word I by trying to serve
others you know why because when you
want to be served you're dependent on
people
maybe not serve you when you want to
serve who can stop it when you want
respect people may not respect you but
when you want to give a respect who can
stop you when you want to be loved you
will not be loved but when you want to
give love who can stop you when you want
and charity people may not give you in
charity but when you want to give
charity who can stop you and therefore
learn to begin your journey from I
the more you want for yourself you'll
remain frustrated the more we want to
give you will remain happy rule number
four grow through life when you want to
achieve success in your career in your
academics in your business in your
profession we will fame and that's the
example of the giraffes
when the baby giraffe is born falls from
such a high distance straight on the
ground
the mothers positions herself right
above the baby giraffe and guess what
she does best gives it a hard kick butt
check ajinomoto pear market arts a lot
party so but just my study habit III
didn't give me a lot come at love cable
news sanika Milhouse Co so as it's just
coming out of the impact Jessica the
model gives a second harder kick now the
guy understands where my couch kyani to
its alpha Riga silsila oh this baby
giraffe starts getting up on its wobbly
legs you know on its wobbly legs and as
the baby giraffe gets up on the bobbly
like Thor Cara okay karana see Connor
paddock or lot more Pima he gets up and
starts running and then the mother
giraffe goes hugs the baby and starts
kissing the baby you know why because
the baby giraffes flesh is very soft and
supple and hyenas and lions love it the
mother knows that I can't be with the
baby giraffe all that I want to go and
get food for the baby
how would I protect it is lip la se la
tomorrow he would not seek a or possess
it or alter her wake or LA tomorrow
automatically jinda giving my mother
giraffe Jessie I were a lot to Marty a
we fail we should get up and we'll fail
again
we should get up and like I always say
don't just go through life grow through
life rule number five focus on the good
it's quite amazing isn't it that when
something stuck in our to the tongue
just keeps going to that tooth until
endless that stuff is out of our - it
just keeps going there now this 31 other
teeth in our mouth when nothing stuck
the tongue can go there and say hey wow
look there's nothing stuck here and go
to one or the other
to Twitter there's nothing stuck in say
hey look amazing there's nothing stuck
here but just the nature of the term
that it keeps going to where something
is stuck and surely we have to deal with
it whenever I travel in my handbag I
always have dental floss and a box of
toothpicks with me just in case
something is stuck I have to take it up
certainly we have to deal with it at the
same time there's a lot of other good
things that we can focus on ladies and
gentlemen it's not just the nature of
the tongue
isn't it the nature of the mind as well
when there is a problem an issue stuck
in a certain area of our life the mind
keeps going to that problem and just
gets stuck into the negativity of trying
to deal with it but this thirty one or
shall I say many many more good things
happening in so many different areas of
our life
but there's no problems no issues stuck
yet the mind only keeps going to those
areas where there are problems it is
necessary therefore for all of us that
we focus on the good that is happening
in our life and deal with the bad or the
problems that are happening in our life
let us not consume our minds with
negativity let us consume our minds with
positivity focus on the positive and
deal with the negative rule number six
live a balanced life most often if not
always a life seemed to be out of
balance and when lives are out of
balance it makes us very irritable you
know when we drive a car we always drive
a car and a car has four wheels a
rhetorical thing to say isn't it you
drive a car on these four wheels and
these four wheels in the car of life
represent first we your personal life
your health your mind yourself the
things that you love to do the things
that you would want to do not have to do
most times we live a life of have to do
I have to study I have to work I have to
pay my bills I have to pay the taxes I
have to do this and I have to do that I
have to go for the social function I
don't have a choice I have to have to
have to have to where did the love to go
which is end up living a life of half
to's and I forgot about our own cells by
subscribing to the pressures that come
from all fronts in our lives before
to live our own lives we don't have time
to unwind we don't have time to spend
with our own selves we don't have time
to be with nature and take a deep breath
and just relish the crispness of the air
we don't have the time to do all of that
especially in the metropolitan city like
this when the pressures are so high and
the pace is so fast we just don't have
time for ourselves ladies and gentleman
and that's one car one we love our car
isn't it personal life or health for
instance such an important thing but at
the cost of destroying if you forget to
pay attention to our own health the
second wheel of the car is family life
demands attention isn't it your personal
life demands attention your family life
demands attention isn't it before
marriage when you are in love they call
it a crush isn't it but after marriage
all that is left is candy crush all the
crushes are in gone and all that you're
left with is a candy crush and all the
headaches coming from all the pressures
one lady went to a doctor and the doctor
said how's your headache madam she said
he's out of town gosh I must tell you
demands a lot of attention your personal
life the first tire do you have one do
you have a personal life is my question
do you have time for your health
even in my hectic schedule I have made
five days of exercise yes still in all
the lectures and all the talks and
everywhere I go because that's what's
going to keep me going I have to give
time to myself because I don't get more
than three and a half to four hours of
sleep so if I don't look at my physical
fitness I'm gone ladies and gentlemen do
you give time for yourself do you have
time for yourself your personal time or
is
a wheel out of balance is that a flat
tire the third wheel tire of the car of
life is your professional life your
personal life needs attention your
family life needs attention your
professional life needs attention and
the fourth is your social life your
friends people around you your
colleagues those relationships that
matter a lot to you those people who
would support you in time of need
because to your spouses to your family
you could speak a little sometimes
certain things are not always confided
with just blood relationships you need
that social side people do me we can
speak open up your heart
how often do we just carry this baggage
of stress and load anxiety and worry in
our heads lugging it all around us
baggage this is social side to our life
a friends you know I have had those
moments where I've snapped even as a
monk because I am a human being this is
because I put this robes of a monk
doesn't mean I become you know a
celestial angel I'm still a human being
when one of those tires is out of order
if I haven't slept well if my health is
out of place I'm going to snap out you
know you carry work pressures at home
you carry home pressures at work ladies
in German irritability is a symptom of
an out of balance life stability in our
responses is a symptom of a life in
balance we are irritable we snap we
react at the drop of a hat
for trivia just because we are out of
balance people who have a balanced life
know how to handle pressure people whose
lives are not balanced sink under
pressure and get so irritable little
things they just kind of snap off rule
number seven face your fears I'm
actually a camera shy person believe it
or not you know when people shoot me
and they just post some clips that's
fine with me but talking to a camera
it's a machine
it's just some electronic machine the
camera doesn't laugh
the camera doesn't cry the camera
doesn't have any interpersonal
reciprocation the dealings and I must
tell you I felt very nervous thankfully
fearful as well to speak into a camera
there's more fear of failure I would say
because you know when you speak into a
camera and if it's relayed and it's put
online how do people see it otherwise
when I'm with people people have seen me
speak and I decided when the motive is
to serve
and contribute we have to face our fears
we have to deal with our fears face them
and rise above them at some point of
time I had to decide to come and speak
so one day I decided that's it I have to
come speak in front of the camera the
first time I did it believe me we will
post that video once you must see me
speaking there stiff expressionless
motionless stoic nonchalant face you
know and I guess I'm kind of slowly
getting better because in order to deal
with these fears you have to face them
it will start somewhere
rule number eight don't worry it's a
beautiful slide when followed in life I
guarantee you life will be different I
guarantee you if this is applied in life
we can have peaceful night's sleep here
it is do you have a problem in life no
then why worry do you have a problem in
life yes can you do something about it
yes then why worry
do you have a problem in life yes can
you do something about it no then why
worry rule number nine choose how to
live your life in the journey of life as
well the take-off which is our birth is
completely beyond our control we didn't
choose our parents we didn't choose
which nation we vimana we didn't choose
which city paper bonnet we didn't choose
a socio-economic class beaver bonnet we
didn't choose our looks we didn't choose
the religion Bhuvana our take off of the
journey of life was completely beyond us
and the landing death even that could be
completely beyond us I've heard many
times people telling me that they would
just love to die by getting a massive
heart attack and dropping dead no
trouble for them no hospitalization no
tubes no needles no trouble cause two
others in one shot go now no matter how
much we might wish that
it's just beyond us how we go and how
the landing happens is completely beyond
us and what about the turbulence the
disturbances the problems during the
journey of our life some of them are
within our control which we can solve
for many problems and issues and the
turbulence caused is completely beyond
our control because it's caused by
situations which are beyond us it's
caused by people who are beyond us yes
ladies and gentlemen in this journey of
life the take-off the planning and the
turbulence is not in our control what is
in our control however is the choices we
can make
and therefore spirituality is about
learning how to make those right choices
when we learn to make those right
choices we learn to live a transformed
happy fulfilled life despite all the
turbulence and problems that are going
on around us
it is said when we are beautiful it's
God's gift to us when we live our life
beautiful it is our gift to God
therefore being a meal is a matter of
birth being a man is a matter of age
being a gentleman is a matter of choice
and as a corollary to that being a
female is a matter of birth being a
woman is a matter of age being a
gentlewoman is a matter of choice let us
all take the spiritual wisdom learn to
make the right choices which have the
dinner control as our gift to God and
thus live our lives as thorough and
perfect ladies and gentlemen
rule number 10 tell great stories I was
telling the story the other day this is
my favorite story I just keep sharing it
all the time this is what really
happened you can't believe this but this
happened i came to london heathrow once
and at London Heathrow I came to the
immigration officer and this immigration
officer elderly man he said so what are
you here for I said to give talks he
said then are you living at your
Woodforde Center I said yeah he said how
long will you stay here for I said about
two weeks he said and can I ask you a
personal question
I said please sir he said I'm married I
[Music]
said you were an Indian aren't you I'm a
monk he said no I was just
cross-checking just in case and then he
said can I ask you another one place I
said yes he said are you not missing
anything in life he thought he caught me
at the wrong foot
are you not missing anything in life I
said of things I am he said what I said
problems he loved my answer
believe me hand on my heart he stamped
my passport and as I'm walking out of
the gate he put his hand on my head
blessing me said son remain like this
son remained like this you will never
have to go through any issues and your
problems in life
dad you know what I mean it's nice to
laugh at but as I walked through the
gate I turned to him and told him look
gentlemen I must tell you something
don't think that me as a monk is free
from problems
anyone who lives in this dog-eat-dog
world as they might say or anyone who
lives in this world full of rat race and
pressures whether it's you who are a
student study or one a few culprits or
business people who's working or married
man or lady who's kind of dealing with
family life or myself is a monk they're
all subject to our own pressures we are
all subject to our own stresses we our
own subject to our own individual
worries and anxieties this to flee was
different rule number 11 utilize your
time well there are four things that we
can never recover in our life a stone
after it has been thrown into the valley
words after they have been spoken an
opportunity once it is missed and time
once it has gone considering the average
lifespan of a human being today to be
about 70 years 17 multiplied by 12 is
840 now that's how many months we have
in our life to live in this world and if
life is represented by a jar and those
840 months by the marbles in the jar
every year 12 marbles are being thrown
out of the charm
last year 12 marbles have gone as well
gone forever never to come back again
look at how many marbles you now have in
the jar to make a difference to leave a
mark
to stand apart
utilize your time well and your time
will treat you well leading you into an
overall sense of well-being in the new
year to come
invest in taking care of your body
invest in nurturing and nourishing your
relationships invest in finding and
discovering your purpose your passion
your calling in order to enhance your
professional growth invest in pursuing
and cultivating a meaningful deep
spiritually connect and for some reason
if you found yourself stuck in any of
these some of these or all of these
areas in the last year
the new year brings a fresh opportunity
to press the refresh button refresh the
page of your life and live well because
at the end of the day remember we are
all just stories
and make sure
is inspiring rule number 12 focus that
one looks at the cream standing on one
leg completely focused into the waters
the crane with one pointed attention is
looking at the waters as the fishes are
swimming inside the water the crane will
allow the tiny the small fish to swim
around and not be satisfied with them
it will allow the fishes the small
fishes to go around and swim around the
crane will focus and wait for the big
fish to come if the cranes seconds with
the small fish it loses the big fish and
if the crane wants the big fish it has
to allow the small fish to pass by and
go around
similarly in life when you want to focus
on what is important we should allow the
small things to pass why we shouldn't be
distracted by the little things
sometimes they'll be interpersonal
issues and conflicts sometimes there
will be some health crises sometimes
there might be a financial crisis so
many things keep happening in life let
the small things pass by and focus on
what's important rule number 13 act with
a vision Thomas Alva Edison once made a
very nice statement he said genius is 1%
inspiration and 99% perspiration
we may have an inspiration in our heart
but 1% strong burning Inferno of an
inspiration but unless that inspiration
is put into action dedicated committed
hard work that 99% perspiration we are
not going to be able to achieve what we
want to achieve and so also when we talk
about dealing with our bad habits
success is 1% inspiration and 99%
perspiration
we need that inspiration but based on
the foundation of that inspiration we
have to put an
dedicated committed hard work that 99%
perspiration what's amazing is that 99%
perspiration is based on the foundation
of that 1% inspiration if the foundation
of a building is in place the very first
thing that we make when it comes to
building a structure a house a beautiful
edifice or a mansion is they put the
foundation in place if the foundation is
in place if it's strong and robust then
all the building block is the bricks the
cement the mortar the Stiggy can go on
and form a beautiful structure for us to
live in for us to dwell in and so also
that 1% inspiration is the foundation of
that 99% perspiration imagine if you're
very inspired to change if you're very
inspired to give up some of your bad
habits but you don't put that hard work
that 99% perspiration what good is that
inspiration or imagine if you keep
putting 99% of perspiration that hard
work that effort the dedicated
commitment but if you don't have that
inspiration to do it in the right
direction and sustain it and get it a
higher shelf life what good is that hard
work and perspiration
therefore success comes by a balance of
the term inspiration which acts as the
foundation and perspiration which acts
as the building blocks to build upon
that foundation I once read a very
interesting Japanese proverb it said
action without vision is a nightmare
if you simply keep acting without having
the right vision the result is a
nightmare and it said vision without
action is a daydream if you simply have
a vision and you don't act upon it all
you have as a result is a daydream I
have rephrased it for our discussion
here today perspiration
without inspiration is a nightmare but
inspiration without perspiration is a
daydream rule number 14 get consumed by
positivity it consumed by the positive
energy focus not on your bad habits get
consumed not by the negative energy of
your bad habit sometimes we just get so
consumed by that all that's playing on
our mind is that no that's meant to be
dealt with focus on the good things that
are happening in your life and to focus
on the good things and be grateful
doesn't happen automatically it's not
our default setting our default setting
is to go towards the negative our
default setting is it to focus on the
negative we have to customize our lives
by being consciously aware we have to
become more mindful and conscious of the
wonderful gifts the wonderful
opportunities the wonderful blessings
that we've been showered with and with
that positive energy but bad positive
emotion of gratitude feel tremendously
empowered to deal with our bad habits to
deal with our challenges and therefore
do not be hateful about what you're
going through in life be grateful for
all those wonderful gifts that have been
given in your life remember 15 take on
challenges I feel challenges are such an
integral part of growth in our life for
example a teacher will always pose
higher and higher challenges to the
students why because the teacher wants
the student to grow in his or her
understanding of the subject mathematics
for instance watch mathematics in
kindergarten and primary school in
secondary school in university is
different why because the challenge
level goes on increasing and the higher
the challenge and
in a better way we are able to crack it
we simply grow deeper in our
understanding of the subject there is no
meaning to life without a challenge and
the symptom of greatness is to accept
that challenge in a very sportive spirit
and learn how to grow deeper in whatever
we are doing
rule number 16 rewrite your mistakes
when you write you will most certainly
end up making mistakes what's truly
great is that right behind you is
attached an eraser and you can actually
correct that mistake and once again
write the right thing
ladies and gentlemen even in our lives
we make so many mistakes and what's
amazing is God has given us the
opportunity the chance to erase them to
correct them and to rewrite our stories
we all make mistakes I remember I once
went for a program and a gentleman came
to me and said Prabhu gee I'm your fan I
said why he said your talks are really
inspiring especially the jokes I said
what about the points man he said the
points are good but the jokes are great
I said to him come on all the jokes are
only meant to really pass on the message
and drive home the point and just as we
were talking and little boy came running
and I said your son right
he said yeah and just following the boy
came a lady I said your daughter right
and the man turned blue and the lady was
like all smiles a year-to-year smile
because she was not as daughter she was
actually his wife the guy turned to his
wife and said Prabhu chakuza they
seriously Neal Innoko one good joke
smart [ __ ] both other day oh my god I
realized God had made a big mistake
there by asking if it was his daughter
when she was actually as wife we all
make mistakes now anyone who comes to me
with people around
I never asked whether this is your son
or daughter or wife of father or mother
I just asked can you kindly introduce me
to everyone please simple isn't it yes
we make mistakes we should learn from
those mistakes erase them correct them
and never repeat them rule number 17 win
the war now the nature of success is
that it gets into our heads and makes us
complacent so the first guys if you've
been successful in keeping up with your
commitment don't let it get into your
head don't get proud don't get
complacent because complacency will stop
your growth and the nature of failure is
whenever we are not able to keep up with
our commitments whenever we are not able
to do what we want to do is that it gets
into a heart and makes us depressed
ladies and gentlemen if in the last week
you haven't been able to keep up with
your commitments don't worry don't get
depressed don't feel guilty that guilt
if it helps you to improve is good but
that guilt if it just sends you into
into sends you into a mental trap that
guilt is no good in fact I always say
this it's not about using a particular
battle it's about winning the war ladies
and gentlemen every war is made of many
small and tiny battles and it's only
utopia of fantasy and imagination to
think that those who are fighting in the
war will win every
that is impossible even during the
Kurukshetra war
when the five brothers the pandavas the
noble ones were fighting with the
hundred cousins the vicious ones the
Kauravas the whole idea was bought
winning the war and the Pandavas kept
losing many battles during the war
Abhimanyu Arjun son was killed her toe
touch Bhima son was killed the five sons
of draupadi were killed so many losses
during that war it's not that the
Pandavas won every battle but they were
certainly victorious in the war and
during those battles when they lost
those battles it's natural that we feel
the press it's natural that we kind of
have the tendency to give up this is
when Lord Krishna came to their rescue
by always bringing their attention to
the final goal to keep their eyes
focused on the final goal of winning the
war
rule number 18 enhance your good habits
I really want all of you to truly truly
introspect if you've decided something
in the last year 2017 and did you truly
work on it through the year and where do
you stand today throughout the day today
till we meet the next morning tomorrow
at eight o'clock I want all of you to
introspect this one word introspection
to see if you've actually worked on what
you've decided or were you a victim of
resolution dissolution and no solution
ladies and gentlemen I often say with
habits are of three kinds the first is
our good habits and when we talk about
good habits for example saying a thank
you this is an example or saying a sorry
being hospitable courteous kind is a
good habit and very often it's just a
habit though very often we could say a
thank you or even say us
and not even mean it we go into the
autopilot mode and that's why we call it
a habit it's just in the autopilot mode
we say thank you we don't mean it we may
say oh sorry we may not mean it and
therefore when it comes to good habits
in the year 2018
let us consciously enhance them not just
sustain and enhance those habits but
consciously enhance those habits which
is basically for example we see say a
thank you we mean thank you Excel for
example we say oh sorry we mean as sorry
as well they're good habits and you
could identify your own good habits and
make sure that we do not continue them
in an autopilot mode in the year 2018 so
with the good habits we don't want to be
in the autopilot mode but you want to
consciously enhance the quality of those
good habits as we enter the year 2018
rule number 19 go through the pain
unless you go through sharpening what is
within you will not come out the pencil
has to go through painful sharpening
before the sharp LED comes out and makes
an impact ladies and gentlemen
similarly in life unless we go to
painful sharpening the best things
within will never come out as they say
no pains no gains rule number 20 do the
right things many of you have many of
you some of you have commented and asked
me this question that all this sounds
easier than done it's easy to say these
things easy to listen to these things
when it comes to practical
implementation application and dealing
with these things in real life it seems
very difficult it seems very hard but
that's very true what you've said is
perfectly true because only the wrong
things come very easy the right things
that we need to do in our life don't
come that easily you know when we do the
wrong things they give us that momentary
pleasure and they're extremely easy to
do although they give us that momentary
pleasure and they're easy to do in the
long run however we have to pay a very
high price in terms of our physical
emotional mental and spiritual
well-being although they give us
pleasure and they are easy God they
really caused a lot of trouble later on
the other hand the right things they
caused pain in the beginning they're
painful to do a lot of hard work
they don't come easy and if you just are
willing to bear that initial pain that
initial hard work the initial discomfort
and that initial could be a long time
actually in the long run these right
things these right habits pay back a
massive premium to us in terms of
sustained pleasure safe pleasure which
has a very high shelf value and it is
not at all destructive to our overall
sense of well-being
this kind of pleasure coming from the
right things Lord Krishna calls these
pleasures in the bhagavad-gita as
sattvic pleasures of pleasures in the
mode of goodness they cause pain in the
beginning discomfort in the beginning
but they pay back a huge premium in
terms of sustained high shelf pleasures
on the other hand Lord Krishna calls
this short-term pleasures come that come
by doing wrong as pleasures in the mode
of ignorance or Tomczyk pleasures these
pleasures are momentarily very exciting
thrilling exhilarating and they easy to
go but in the long run we have to pay a
huge price therefore ladies and
gentlemen do not worry so much about
what is easy or hard worry about what is
right and wrong the right things may be
hard but we should be doing it in a long
term interest the wrong things may come
easy but we should be avoiding them in
our long term interest therefore even if
being polite sensitives we're sportive
kind to others may be hard even if
putting all these things that we've
spoken in the last couple of days into
practice base sounds very hard and
difficult but that's the right thing to
do ladies and gentleman in our
transformative journey we have to worry
about the right thing to do not the easy
thing to do and right things require a
lot of hard work but bit by bit as we
work hard we can get there remember 21
get up and start running a grab given me
Yas munakata a UROP jeevan may success
prop carnage a taeho to me
[Music]
Drita's Aegina person ahead
determination Seguin apart a peerage
rakhna papa patient banana papaya or
even sub capelin Hikaru table pick a
barge even Meno TRPA challenges appear
on fellow Japan a hunger jockey hey
Ernie Raja jab a success Kokoschka
subsea shatru hain near asha
Rubini Raja jaja to sab kuch colberto
bikini rosh hashanah
topaz Madeira for our Carolina
yo Madeira a pop Nebojsa cogent APA
formatted Arab ryouichi oto robots are
you chase a Georgia German pergi repair
Oh Jesse bechara semana Capretta Karthik
Makaha area
takuma Pacheco Pavarotti Rosco Oh
Georgia not mawr PA ultimate chachaka or
Georgia or bass a place food would do
Barakat a car mega predator / / Moscow
Baraka career appear tomorrow
Georgia not my PA but some agita
Jeremy Poochyena Karuna to la cartera in
a paragraph of Ligny but it conjure pero
el jardín anacapri at IOD Roberta
[Music]
veromarcos column our PA dr. gira got a
savage attack ad Macaulay rector Haruna
tomislav appear an apple a giraffe
kabocha tgzip-- organic a Fresno pepper
or Tajima apne Bachchan Pierre Alexandre
a Madeira believe at Ajanta a cage angle
may break our pursue a shell nombre de
jour now jad pranayamas berapa sanlúcar
pain or Madeira to be cheeky sod she
shook Assad a missionary a verb ah
heartily giotto's particular japan-korea
a silly sub sapele Jessica Jennifer
Roscoe lot Marty a Takeo uttanasan hey
dobe are a lot mawr PA
pakusa us Nicki de cría who yarder ahead
devar a lot Marty a rocky cable attorney
Dorna param McRae Jeevan whatever
channel here I challenges angry or I'm
giving in I feel only liquid Margera
my job be challenges I chickeny Barbie
are view which massacre which but it's
not sequel woodcutter ni saku kara naked
are messy cook cooking color yogig
varanasi cooking yes success
coochie-coochie shaker / vanessa kirby
rule number 22 find the right balance in
the world out there today people have a
wrong idea of success people think
success means achievement and people
think success means having all what the
world is promoting to you so the more
you have the more successful you are and
the more happier you are that's a
completely wrong idea of success that
people have now when you are wanting to
achieve and you wanting to get the best
and you wanting to get there all the
time obviously have to work hard
loads of people are putting in 14 16 18
hours of work not prioritizing their
health not prioritizing their hobbies
not prioritizing their family not
prioritizing their spirituality not
prioritizing their unwinding them saying
how much do you prioritize there's so
many things seeking your attention is
there a risk of people spreading
themselves too thin and how do you
figure that out how do you how do you
fly i don't think so it's a question of
spreading yourself out i think it's a
question of finding the right balance
irritability and lack of satisfaction is
is is an outcome often life out of
balance you know a life out of balance
now it's like it's like when you an
artist is wanting to make a painting or
a pencil sketch and if he's sharpening
the pencil someone comes in says hey man
you're wasting your time sharpening a
pencil but unless i sharpen the pencil
whatever you do is going to be extremely
blunt so if you even want to be
effective at work and achieve it's
better that you be internally focused if
you're not focused and if you're not
internally mentally stable your output
at the workplace is low as well
i'm saying that if you prioritize those
things that mean to you you work on
yourself you work on your internal self
the consequence of that would be will be
super productive and less
number of hours people are taking much
longer to do something that they could
have done a much shorter amount of time
because they're distracted they're not
focused they're not together
what you're saying is very simple but
it's not easy
absolutely so let's cut to the chase
sure give it all to our viewers a few
practical solutions to continue to focus
on oneself and not be distracted by the
noise that there are subtle tactical
strategies number one start taking in
Inventor irregularly okay don't just go
with the flow if you're not even paying
attention to you if you're not even
cognizant if you're not even identifying
those areas you're not going to work on
them so first identify that I need to
work on this understand that this is a
priority step two is regularly take time
out if you don't take a break you're
simply leading to a breakdown a break is
going to help you get to break through
but a lack of break is going to get you
to a breakdown if you have ever read the
book the monk who sold his Ferrari it's
a guy who's just working achieving
putting his 200% and gets a cardiac
arrest at a young age in the courtroom
what is it on the part you've achieved
everything and you know massive failure
because you couldn't work on your life
so - let's take a break now you might
say oh man I'm really busy how am I
going to take a break
which basically means you don't got it
right if you can't take a break you're
leading to a breakdown prioritize that
break so you can achieve a breakthrough
yeah I do break so not easy even me my
life is 150 to 200 sometimes 250 flights
a year exactly that's how much I travel
how do you take a break I have learned
the art of unwinding on the go how do
you do that you have to do it on the go
prioritize it I listen to your favorite
music read your favorite book eat your
favorite food
you know meditate while or you're on the
go sit there I don't want this then
learn the art of cutting off from the
surroundings while you're on you sitting
in the car driving back home you're
sitting on a 17 hours flight to New York
you know what are you going to do all
those 17 hours learn the art of cutting
off
surroundings and going within I do that
remember 23c challenges as opportunities
assembled in 1914 there was a massive
explosion in West Orange New Jersey
United States of America 10 buildings in
a factory owned by the legendary
inventor Thomas Edison were engulfed by
flames six to eight fire departments
rushed to the scene but could not curb
the chemical fueled inferno
after having dried all that he could as
Thomas Edison calmly stood there
watching the fire destroy his entire
life's hard work his 24 year old son
Charles came over and stood next to him
and a childlike voice Edison said to his
son Charlie go and get your mother and
her friends they'd never be able to see
a spectacular fire like this in their
entire life astonished and shocked by
father's response Charles asked Thomas
Edison
our entire Factory is being burnt down
to ashes bed Thomas Edison replied in
complete composure yes
our factory is being burnt down to ashes
but all the mistakes we've made so far
in the factory have also been burnt down
to ashes we will start all over again
tomorrow that evening Thomas Edison told
a New York Times reporter although I'm
67 years old and I'm completely
exhausted from running around and trying
to control the file tomorrow I'll start
all over again
afresh and so he did the next day was a
fresh beginning for Thomas Edison and
his son Charles in trying to rebuild
what had been destroyed by the fire
often this is what life does unto us our
dreams are shattered hopes broken
efforts baffled great people they don't
cry they try to rebuild their dreams
great people don't give up live up to
the challenges that life throws at them
great people don't go through they grow
through the difficulties that come on
their path they start all over again
with great hope with great determination
with great grit
and that is why we reach the highest
peaks of success that most people only
aspire for that is why I say no
challenges no success no challenges no
success rule number 24 go beyond the
obvious a teacher teaching math to a
class of six-year-olds asked a boy
called Erna in class Erna if I give you
two mangoes and two mangoes how many
will you have I've no said five the
teacher said uh now if I give you one
too - mine was and one two two mangoes
how many will you have five replied I
now
the teacher was upset but remember that
I knows mom had said that my mom doesn't
like mangoes he liked strawberries so
she changed her example if I give you
two strawberries and two strawberries
how many do you have
so replied Allah or the teacher was
pleased by the change of strategy just
to confirm that our now had understood
his math right
she asked her now again if I give you
two mangoes and two mangoes how many
will you have are no replied five the
teacher was now annoyed how can two and
two strawberries before and two and two
mangoes be five or no replied I already
have one mango in my bag madam who was
right was the teacher wrong no because
two plus two is four
was I'll never know because 2+2 this
fall and one man when my rag makes it
why isn't it a fact that all kinds of
conflicts come because of the gap
between technical ripeness and practical
rightness the teacher was technically
right technical rightness means to see
the obvious technical rightness means to
see what is visible
Poorna was practically right practical
rightness means to see beyond the
obvious practical rightness means to see
beyond what is visibly see practical
rightness means to see the hidden Mangal
ladies and gentlemen very often all our
conflicts come because the gap between
the technical and practical rightness
the next time you see someone not fit
into your definition of what is
technically right please do not be
judgmental go beyond the obvious go
beyond the same you try to look for the
hidden mango which will truly help you
understand the person and resolve the
conflicting situation that you are in
you number-25 break the mold when you're
wanting to do something out of the box
there's always going to be opposition
from a society where parents want you to
subscribe to a certain things a settled
job a settled life in terms of family
and your thinking completely out of the
box as soon as you want to do something
out of the box you're going to have to
face challenges from the family side
after a while however when my family saw
where I was reaching how I was impacting
people's lives however how I was really
able to make a difference in the world
they accepted it very well and I feel in
terms of coping up with the challenges
of how my friends have moved on the
industry I think it's a question of
self-discovery I hate I hate being a
part of a mold that the world created
for me I don't want to subscribe to the
mold that the world creates for you I
don't want to live a life in a paradigm
that the world is created for me I want
to discover my own mold I want to have a
paradigm that I have invented you know
only when you discover yourself only
when you live a life for what you are
created is when you feel happy satisfied
not just happy and satisfied you're
super effective even in the corporate
world today loads of people are just
living
life which they are not created for
because it pays the bucks and why do
they need the box to pay the taxes to
pay the pills bills to pay the mortgages
but they're not living a life of what
they are created for so it's basically
kind of you know fitting in just because
it pays you but I decided I didn't want
to fit it so when I saw others moving on
my friends my colleagues moving on high
up I really did not feel insecure at all
because I didn't want to fit in to be
someone else I wanted to find myself
discover myself there's as soon as you
of successful in your self-discovery man
you are effective and completely
satisfied
rule number 26 change your vision a
little boy once came running to his
mother and asked her what are you doing
wrong she'll play
I'm making a beautiful embroidered
design on this nice glut the little boy
looked up to the cloth securely and in
the wooden ring the home and complained
a design all I can see is just some
colored threads yellow blue red black
pink all tangled up all messed up into
each other all complication and you call
it a design
[Music]
picked up the little boy put him on her
lap
and said to him now look at it my son
and the boy saw a beautiful design an
incredible pattern a systematic plan and
a layout a one wing on this plot the
mother said to the boil
when you look at the clot from your side
all you see is a mess
when you look at the clot from my side
all you see is a beautiful design
applaud ladies and gentlemen when we go
to the helpless oh well Ming challenges
in our life for no fault of ours or no
fault of anybody else and we cannot do
anything to sort it out if we see and
look at it
all we see is a mess all we see is
situations and events tangled up and
jumbled up to create that mess but when
we look at the same situation from
life's point of view from God's point of
view we see a beautiful design a pattern
a plan evolving in
in fact for a beautiful design of
embroidery to happen on one side you
cannot avoid the mess on the other side
and it's not just the nature of
embroidery such as the nature of life as
well this outlook actually gives us a
very deep sense of inner strength and
fortitude to face such helpless oval
main challenges in our life thus I say
change your vision and your vision will
change you rule number 27 make informed
and transformed choices we have put in
many many complicated situations I want
to offer all of you a very powerful tool
a very simple one when you are talking
about making a choice weigh the
consequences and just decide which of
the two consequences you are okay to
bear moral dilemmas are easy to solve
because moral dilemmas are between good
and bad ethical dilemmas are hard to
solve because ethical dilemmas are
between bad and bad or good and good
remember this always you will have to
make one choice you're not going to be
spared by life you will always have to
make one choice choices means two things
to remember informed choices and
transformed choices we should make
informed choices what is an informed
choice is based on proper knowledge
based on proper deliberation based on
proper consideration based on proper
analysis not half is hardly whimsically
made choices and what is transform
choices choice is based on a spiritual
strength so when we have a combination
of informed and transform then we make a
choice because informed we know what to
do but we can't do it unless we
definitely need to make
transform choices and therefore they say
and an elegant person will open your
mind a handsome person will open your
eyes are cool Ratana recognize women but
a gentle man will open your heart what
to speak of an intelligent handsome
gentle man this is what I appeal to all
of you become intelligent handsome
gentle man
rule number 28 fix your life first what
did you do to be who you are right now
yeah I think if you if you are on an
airline and then on a flight
the cabin crew will come announce that
if there be a lack of oxygen supply in
the cabin masks will come from the panel
above your head and secure them normally
and breathe normally and make sure your
mask is in place before you assist and
help others exact so you truly cannot
help others unless you owe yourself in
place and when we talk about putting
your life in place like my personal life
in place I feel there is a great need to
give that priority to fix your life so
yes there were challenge it's moving
from being a HP engineer to a lifestyle
engineer moving from being a pampered
son to a monk moving from living in
comfort to living in meager facilities
in the ashram in the monastery there
were challenges but these were all
external challenges the internal
challenges were am I missing out you're
out there if I put my fire out they
would probably be really elevated to a
very high position in the industry so
initially when I just came in the
challenge was am I missing out and that
challenge was taken care of by seeing
the kind kind of lives that were being
impacted by what I was doing the
satisfaction I felt and trying to bring
the difference and making that impact
was able to kind of deal with that
challenge of failing did I miss out on
something I don't think I must start on
anything at any point because seeing
people's life changed is what very brave
brought me that great joy
rule number 29
act as an instrument now when we see all
of these pencils lying here on the table
can any of this pencil make a pencil
sketch by itself can any one of these
write a poem by themselves can any of
the Spencer's actually draw a plan a
construction plan for a building
no the pencil maker tool the pencil then
you can actually truly serve your
purpose and your in the hands of an
expert in the hands of an expert artist
a beautiful sketch is made Pablo Picasso
the great artist was one time walking on
the streets and a lady came up to him
and said hey Picasso you're such a great
artist can you make a pencil sketch of
my place because who made that sketch in
a jiffy in less than 30 seconds and
handed it over to the lady and said 1
million dollars madam she said you've
made it less in less than 30 seconds
what do you need the 1 million dollars
for Picasso said the 1 million dollars
is not for making it in less than 30
seconds the 1 million dollars is for the
30 years of hard work which makes me do
it in less than 30 seconds in the hands
of an expert architect the pencil can
make a plan
the hands of an expert poet writer the
pencil can write a poem or a story yes
ladies and gentlemen when we act as
instruments like Spencer and the hands
of God in the hands of our teachers our
gurus our mentors our experienced
trustworthy guides truly we will be able
to make an incredible impact on the
world regardless of who we are and what
color we are off
rule number 30 let your choices define
you pigma achma open a vertical severe
severe school genetically jaggery or
baton a school Janus a Safin car can be
up to Jinping ketchup Bahama limit a
pizza home couscous uniquely jaga delta
t don t scenic a supercar cabana lady
agatha t to be paid made our data to
compete meters copies are made art to
kibou Harrogate aa table job is beta
code jaga area the money beat izakaya
key to MU J doe car and o2 school
konasana chatty Botanica paella carrot
to be sorry
teachers months in Africa P or disregard
sorry with their artist Irish students
women's in Africa play
Monica school - Jeru Jana pre-debate a
moussaka - Musa Dagh car and ok my
school kyu-jong Monica Bella car junkie
- Bhavan sulky or district are you ok -
squeaky headmaster chime go school Jana
ecology Jana Heilig a absurd quad
Okeechobee school cappella Dino Tata Tom
number out sahaja Tata nage attained a
uniform a school bag negative a Brittany
notebook it may copy Bianca Mills
atrophy Jeevan maybe her wash her Sol
hum quick copy ignored book multi a team
soup acid but normally notebook her
Siham Khadija tea business Aldo Hadassah
Treme of which Arkady king pages per in
Panama / APNIC aleca hispano package
oppress rain who chopped gay
relationships someone danke chapter who
chopped professional life Kate chapters
couch obtain eg say heard healthy Kate
chapters our coach up cadet McGee even
spiritual life K chapters Allah garlic
broccoli chapters how many pets LaSalle
K
Doha Joss at Rockies ten teen soap a
sequela Pinocchio McNeil Akane good
chapters Berea Chi handwriting militia
gay or could chapters gen John Bonavia
hominem ska kuch din hamari sambandham a
which can lease a couch karna said
general manager yeah
come on a professional like me how many
code chapter general Binaca beg me push
cover - hey kiddo huzzah axe Rocky Joey
no become familiar is Qahhar panna her
pressed her page Holly hey Rob
the hamari Choi's head he hung inferno /
up in age with someone monkey chapter
say hearth k chapter professional life
gate chapter openly at we have means
even gay chapter opening monastic Sun to
Lanka chapter Cassie handwriting
Millican a chi and writing me back
ginger l've an actor like me or a silly
jia CVM choice ke you see prokhorovka a
mirage evanka under power
over rule number 31 follow the change I
believe that the seven greatest I would
say the seven words which are the
greatest enemy of growth and progress in
any field including what I'm doing a are
we have always done it this way
Nokia thought we've always done it this
way they are out you know blockbuster
thought they've always done it this way
Netflix threw them out if I as a monk
thought that IV have always done it this
way the monks in the past have always
spoken this way they've always been this
way well I would be out as well
my mind not wanting to be out was not
because I wanted to be the center my not
wanting to be out was so that I can I'll
reach out to people and help make a
difference in their lives so obviously I
had to change with times obviously I had
to change my job then obviously I had to
bring in a bunch of you have a bit of
humor in there obviously I would have to
speak lines which will resonate with
people it's like I hate using our but
it's like playing old wine in a new
bottle right principles never change
values never change knowledge and wisdom
doesn't change but how you bring it to
people that certainly can change and I
believe that's what's resonated with
people it's not that I'm saying anything
new is the same visit am the same
knowledge many people are speaking it
but just the way you package it so Nokia
failing and packaging themselves rightly
coming into digital photography
blockbuster denied when Netflix up
Netflix approached them they're out and
if I think I don't change I don't keep
up with the times
well I'm outdated if you're not updated
you are outdated whether its
spirituality or the industry out there
it doesn't matter
rule number 32 live in the now I think
when we talk about being in the present
we don't have to start getting into the
present when the pressure is high we
need to start practicing being in the
present when the pressure is low there's
a very nice quote that I read once in
one of the
Barack's of the indian army which said
when you sweat a lot in times of peace
you be less in times of war
IPL for instance cricket now when the
match is on the world tournaments on the
the competition stuff is you right there
and under the spot which means the
pressure is high and you need to be
focused you need to be present you can
only do it effectively when you learn to
be present in the smaller things of life
I often tell people that when we talk
about being present one thing that we
should start practicing is start being
physically present like I give the
example I have a glass of juice here you
know when I'm sipping this mango juice
why do I need to watch television why do
I have to keep checking messages on my
phone what I'm doing by looking at the
television while looking at the phone is
being distracted from drinking the juice
so I'm drinking the juice let me just
drink the juice what's happening is I'm
being present physically present now
it's not so much about just being
drinking the juice but about cultivating
the attitude behind drinking the juice
or being present and what I'm doing I
also tell people beyond being physically
present we need to also be emotionally
present very often you see people today
are talking to each other chatting with
each other they're looking around here
and there
they're scrolling on their phones
they're looking at their messages
they're sending whatsapp messages what
they're doing is they're completely
getting distracted and not learning to
live in the now being emotionally
present means when I'm talking to you
for instance I am with you I'm not
looking at this plant behind me I'm not
looking at the camera here I'm not
looking at the cup of juice I am looking
at you I'm soaking in every single word
as you speak
that's not just about speaking it's
about cultivating the attitude of being
present rule number 33 increase the
standard of your life
whether you drive a fox wagon or you
drive a Bentley the road remains the
same doesn't it whether you speak on a
Samsung or you speak on an iPhone X
whoever you're calling remains the same
whether you're flying economy or you're
flying business the destination area
heading remains the same isn't it
whether you're wearing a simple fast
track all you wear an Omega or a Rolex
the time remains it's quite amazing how
we work ourselves up so much with
increasing the standard of living that
we forget to increase the standard of
our life and which is why wherever I
travel I make an appeal to people
there's nothing wrong with an Omega and
nothing wrong with a Bentley god bless
you with that and if you have it drive
at no problem but it is trying to
enhance and increase and improvise the
standard of your living please please do
not compromise with the standard of your
life it's not the standard of your
living that makes you happy it is a
standard of your life that makes it
happy and very often we forget to give
attention to those things that can truly
make us
[Music]
which is why I like I always say things
that I'm talking about they have utility
value right not happiness value travel
business rather first-class travel no
problem drive apparently no problem but
in doing so never ever compromise on
those principles that also improve the
standard of your life and therefore I
always say some people are so poor so
poor so absolutely for that all they
have is money that's all that's all
I consider that life a power district in
life if all you have is money you're the
poorest person in the world because
there's more to life than money and
there's way more to life than what money
can buy and therefore are many times say
if you want to truly know how rich you
are drop it here and see how many hands
come forth to wipe that deal ladies
actually a happiness a happiness and I
increased and of life is not in things
it's in people it's relationships it's
meaningful heartfelt deep bondings of
love that bring fulfillment to the heart
it was meaningful exchanges of love that
we share with each other and
relationships that brings true joy to
the heart and isn't it the greatest
irony it's something that brings in the
greatest fulfillment be very
conveniently neglect in just running
after increasing and enhancing a
standard of living
rule number 34 fine balance the pencil
maker tool the pencil that you know what
is truly important is what lies within
you so as externally we have our work
certainly we have our personality but
internally as a person we have to also
develop so pencil is about finding the
balance between the external and the
internal the external is the casing the
internal is the lead lead that makes an
impact so while we lead a life of
valuables externally we must also
prioritize the values internally while
we lead a life of personality externally
we also need to prioritize being a good
person internally while we live a life
of charisma externally we also need to
live a life of character internally so
the balance between the external and the
internal is the balance of the lead in
the pencil in the case of a pencil
yeah rule number 35 have hope I think
there's this one aspect that we all need
to accept and come to terms with in life
this is going to be things that are
beyond a
control let's not fight this back and
let's not come into the mode of
controller ship thinking that
everything's in my hands
that thinking that everything's in my
hands can disappoint us for a straight
us when things don't go our way
so I think that's one aspect that I
talked about this come to terms with it
that there's going to be things that
don't don't go my way and everything
doesn't go by my watch life has its
watch higher powers have their watch and
things will come to us also you know
this this bulbs right up here yeah you
know the lighting of the whole studio of
every shooting it's quite amazing
this bulbs giving their light but
there's many bulbs in the storeroom who
are waiting there to come in the studio
and give their light so that the
shooting can happen when will that bulb
in the studio ever get a chance to come
up here not the beauty of life is at the
bulb up here doesn't last forever
no bulb is lasted forever and no bulb
will last forever
no speaker has lasted for him no speaker
will last forever no actor has lasted
forever in terms of their fame no actor
will last forever no athlete no sports
person has lasted forever and no sports
person will last forever just like this
bulb everyone has their time
everyone has their day and that day
doesn't last for ever so which basically
means the bulb here won't be there one
day and the bulb in the storeroom is
going to get its chance to come to this
lampshade one day to light up the studio
you know what the question in the mind
of that little bulb bear is I agree sir
all this philosophy understood sounds
good all this gone yes sounds great
all this sounds great but how do I
continue so I think the parameter
the principle be the value the epoch
that actually helps us continue with
perseverance and patience is hope hope
is that one element that can keep us
going the worst thing to happen in life
is to lose hope and be hopeless so if
you're sitting there waiting for our
turn to come up against hope one day I
will also have my time and my place when
how we do not know because these are
factors that are completely beyond our
control
Wilma 36 choose greatness so his
question is how does luck or destiny
what role does it play in victory or
success right is it all hard work is it
all destiny what is it now in my humble
opinion destiny is the situations that
come to you which are beyond your
country for example you didn't choose
your parents didn't you choose if you
were this time that was destined you
born as animal you marry Bob premium
about organizing have you ever thought
like that never did you ever choose your
looks it's a knock over you choose no
one looks as good as your facebook
profile picture and no one looks as
obvious there are other garbage of Noah
[Music]
so situations situations are destiny
you didn't choose them they came to you
if someone comes in and serves me I
didn't choose it it came to me that
situation is this time but my response
to the situation is my choice the
response is not destiny what I choose is
my choice and when I choose it that
decides my future destiny this is why
they say man is the maker of this
destiny not situations situations will
remain what they are but how you
responded to those situations is
completely and entirely your choice you
have that situation which is the style
now you have a choice to work hard to
cultivate that attitude that attitude is
not destiny that attitude is a choice
and when you choose that attitude
hopefully victory will come to you right
away even if it doesn't come to you
right away we have sown the seed that we
pay back the seed that a soul will
certainly rectify now Enya's down the
line 20 years down the line or later
this is why persistence sticking it out
it's so much essential rule number 37
prioritize mindfulness the word
mindfulness is a big thing in the world
today mm-hmm I was in San Francisco and
I was invited to speak at Salesforce
okay and Marc Benioff what are the
things he's done at sales forces is
prioritized mindfulness for every single
employee every single floor of their
headquarters in Salesforce has a
mindfulness zone people can go there
practice mindfulness in fact every year
they have this conference called
Dreamforce in the month of November or
two hundred thousand American top-notch
professionals come for the conference
and in that four to five days conference
the last day is the mindfulness day
where they invite people who can speak
to their to these professionals so that
they can learn the art of internally
connecting stabilizing their minds
because even Marc Benioff realized when
people are together the output is much
greater then when we are just distracted
and lost you know so the paycheck is
never an issue but if you cut corners
the organisation never grow so I think
yes even in terms of profitability and
organizational growth spirituality does
make a difference because it gives a
person good character integrity a
certain values where the person
contributes the must rule number 38 be
the best version of yourself when I talk
about self-confidence I talk about
trying to be the best version of
yourself you know we are constantly
updating our apps we're constantly
updating our operating systems whether
it's an iOS or an Android yeah
and the updation of the apps or the
operating systems means to bring the
best versions of what exists and
whenever you're updating to a higher
version of yourself you have to be able
to give the best of yourself to it if
you stick to the older version you reach
the plateau and you don't have to work
harder when you update yourself to a
higher version you have to give the best
of yourself in two hundred percent of
your energy there yeah hard work coming
out of the comfort zone which is where
many times I say you are your own
competition actually that's true nobody
is your competition that's true we have
to compete with ourselves every single
moment every single day to get better
than ourselves
to get better versions of ourselves to
get the best version of ourselves so
when I talk about self-confidence I talk
about being the best version of yourself
and having that full confidence that I
can crack it I can get there real number
39 transform currency to happiness
it's amazing how money can be known by
so many different ways in a temple
church or charity it's called a donation
in a school it's called a fee in a
marriage dowry and in a divorce alimony
when you owe money to someone it's
called a debt when you pay it to the
government
it's called a tax in a court it's a fine
when you receive it regularly after
retirement it's called a pension when an
employer gives it to a worker it's
called a salary when a master gives it
to a servant it's called a wage when
children receive it it's an allowance
and when you borrow it from a bank it's
called a loan when you offer it after a
good service it's called a tip when paid
to a kidnapper it's called a ransom when
only really received in the name of a
service is called a bribe and when used
to share and to serve others
it's called happiness there's nothing
wrong in possessing money the problem is
when money possesses you earn more money
fulfill your needs utilize your money to
share and serve others and transform the
value of your money from currency to
happiness
rule number 40 find your drive a simple
small purse and sanskrit the reverse
which is muqam guru devo cello even a
dumb man can speak upon whom long Hayate
aguirre me
even a lame man can cross the mountain
yatra pitamaha one day she guru
Dena param it's by the grace of sri guru
and
that one can do what we are doing and
therefore if you ask me what is my
motivation to keep going I don't even
think I am inspiring millions or crores
as you said people are watching and
people are hearing it's not my knowledge
it's the knowledge coming from God it's
the knowledge coming from my guru and so
many other monks in the monastery from
whom Allah I simply act as a microphone
a microphone simply amplifies the voice
of the speaker so if there's something
that's motivating people it's not me
it's the knowledge and the power of that
grace that is behind me which is unseen
to your eyes you can't see that but
that's the life that I live when you
don't see me on screens I am in a
monastery in a small little room every
morning practicing my spiritual sadhana
every morning connecting to God through
the chanting of the holy names every
morning I sit and listen to the other
monks I am not only speaking I sit there
I hear others you know I learn from them
and I'm tremendously inspired by the
picture that I showed you in the
Prabhupada his life and tremendously
inspired by the example
and of course my guru rather not my eyes
tirelessly keeps on going and serving if
there's anything that motivates me
it's my chanting it's my hearing it's a
company of my guru and other like-minded
monks that's what keeps rule number 41
get out of your comfort zone we are all
created to fly to live by the incredible
potential that we have all been invested
with but often we sit on our branches
clinging to the things that are familiar
to us remaining stuck in our comfort
zones not willing to venture out not
willing to take risks the possibilities
are endless but for most of us they
remain undiscovered because we continue
to conform to the familiar to the
comfortable to the mundane so for the
most part our lives are mediocre instead
of exciting thrilling and fulfilling
what is the branch that's holding you
back from flying high what's the fear
that's stopping you from taking a risk
what is the weakness that's inhibiting
your growth unless we cut off the
branches we are clinging to and free
ourselves we can never take off and
reach new heights in our life what are
you waiting for
cut the branch and take your flight rule
number 42 ignore the noise a vegetable
vendor used a white board with the words
fresh vegetables sold here to attract
people to buy his vegetables a man came
up to him and said simply by seeing we
can tell that your vegetables are so
fresh why do you need to advertise them
as fresh crop off the word fresh the
vendor did so leaving behind the words
vegetables sold here on the board
another man came up and said we know
you're selling vegetables not fruits why
don't you wipe out the word vegetables
the vendor complied left on the board
now with two words sold here after a
while an elderly lady approached him and
said if you're sitting in the market
you're not giving your veggies for free
I'll take off that soul the vendor
removed the sold and the white board had
only one word left here a school boy
passing by teased the vegetable seller
saying everyone in the world knows
you're sitting here not there why the
here the vegetable seller I raised the
last word making the white board clean
and empty
another person came up and said only a
stupid man would keep such a nice
whiteboard empty why don't you write
something on it to advertise your
vegetables everybody around us has an
opinion to make everybody around us has
a suggestion to offer and most often
with the best intentions but if we end
up listening to what everybody else has
to say we may forget to do or - we are
inspired
what are we are meant to do in the noise
of others suggestions and opinions don't
lose your voice
take good advice could also learn the
art of navigating through that advice to
follow your own journey
rule number 43 don't evaluate life based
on face value anything that you evaluate
by face value saying this is bad could
actually turn out to be good give me an
example an example is how I came to the
world and social media there was a
particular clip on whatsapp that started
circulating someone had played mischief
had taken a joke out of context and it
started circulating it in fact my inbox
whatsapp was filled with the same video
3.8 megabytes
the day I got it three years back and I
was worried God what I'm saying could
get me in trouble
and I thought God this is this is a
difficult situation in fact I even
called a lawyer to see what the
repercussions could be because what I
had said could bring me in controversy
and it's quite amazing it was that clip
that actually brought me to the world so
what you see as a curse could turn into
a blessing what you see as bad could
turn into good so never ever evaluate
any situation based on its face value
something you think is good could be
absolutely destructive for you and
something which you think is absolutely
bad and destructive could turn out to be
something constructive something that in
Steve Jobs say therefore connect the
dots backwards yeah rule number 44 untie
your mental blocks a farmer had three
donkeys and was taking them for sale to
the market on the way he saw a river and
desired to take a dip there was an issue
though he only had two ropes and thus
would be able to tie only two of his
three donkeys to a tree how to tie the
third one he wondered around there he
saw a wise man and approached him for a
rope to tie his third donkey the man did
not have a rope but had a brilliant
suggestion it told the farmer tie the
two donkeys up to a tree with the ropes
you have and make sure that the third
donkey is watching then simply pretend
to tie the third one the farmer followed
the man's advice and went for a depth in
the river when he came back he saw that
the donkeys
stood exactly at the same spot where he
left them he thanked the wise man untied
the donkeys and patted the third one so
it starts moving as well after going a
little distance he turned around and was
surprised to see the third donkey still
standing at the very same spot he tried
cajoling and talking to the donkey it
did not help he tried to push the donkey
from behind but it refused to move from
the spot helpless the farmer came back
to the man who asked him
did you untie the third donkey untie but
I never tied him up replied the farmer
the man said you know that the donkey
doesn't it still thinks it is tied up
the farmer then went through the
imaginary motions of untying the donkey
and guess what
sure enough the donkey moved immediately
as do released and walked over to join
its two friends what's holding us back
from moving ahead and reaching our
dreams is it a lack of resources is it a
lack of opportunities is it a lack of
support or are we tied up by the
imaginary ropes of doubt fear hesitation
yes we certainly need to work on the
external parameters needed for our
success what is even more important is
that we untie our mental blocks and
expedite our journey towards our goal
rule number 45 be consistent Healthcare
is shifting from treatment to prevention
going to the dentist regularly is
important not just when you were in pain
brushing his teeth twice a day every day
and visiting the dentist twice a year
could have prevented the pain he is
experiencing now why wait for problems
to occur in our life if we can
proactively address them and save
ourselves so much pain and going to the
gym regularly is important not just when
you want a summer body small acts of
love and kindness done regularly are
important not just the big kills given
on birthdays and anniversaries it is the
small things done brightly and
consistently that make a huge difference
in our lives
success is less about intensity and more
about consistency
rule number 46 change your outlook a
tourist who was walking around the city
came upon a construction site he saw
three men busy with their task of laying
bricks wanting to check the inspiration
the motivation with which they were
engaged in the exact same job he asked
the first man what he was doing and the
man said he was laying bricks when he
asked the second man the exact same
question the man said he was building a
wall when he turned to the third man and
asked what he was doing he said he was
building a cathedral three men doing the
exact same
but their outlook to their work is so
different the first man an ordinary
outlook get your job done
the second man a normal outlook make
something big that can make you big
money and the third man an extraordinary
outlook seeing the bigger picture not
the brick not the wall but the Cathedral
and doing his bit playing his small part
in making something spectacular such
inspired individuals are happy to be a
part of a larger purpose happy to work
together as a team giving their 200% to
what they do not only do they feel fully
satisfied with their work not only do
they grow professionally but they become
heroes often unsung heroes in creating
something incredibly amazing during one
of his visits to NASA jf Kennedy asked a
janitor mopping up the floor waters job
at NASA was and the gentleman instantly
replied I'm helping send a man to the
moon so are you laying a break building
a wall or creating a towering cathedral
change your outlook
and you will be out spending rule number
47 focus on what you have it was a lazy
Sunday afternoon to school going friends
in a small town had a crazy idea they
rounded up three goats from a farm close
by and painted the numbers one two and
four on their sides that night they let
the goats loose inside the school
building the next morning when the
teachers star children entered the
school they could literally smell
something was wrong they saw goats
droppings all over the place and
concluded that goats had entered the
building now it was a mission to locate
the goat a team was assigned to look for
the goats and very soon the three goats
with the numbers one two and four
painted on them without the school
authorities were relieved but
simultaneously worried we found one two
and four
where was the goat number three the
search team spent the rest of the day
looking for the goat number three there
was panic frustration the school
declared a holiday for the students only
unto their joy the teachers helpers and
team boys everybody will is he looking
for goat number three which of course
was never found you know why because
it's simply did not exist
aren't we all like the search team in
the school we have our goats were right
in front of us we all have a unique
ability that no one in the world can
replicate but instead of making the most
of what we have instead of focusing on
our gifts our strengths our potential we
often continue to look for the elusive
missing non-existent goat number three
we keep worrying about and cheesy the
missing piece
what we lack what we have tried hard for
and never formed what doesn't exist in
us and I'm not even saying we shouldn't
try we have to try our best before
knowing something is not meant for us
but after trying hard for long and still
not being able to reach even the basic
success in doing something I guess it's
time to ask ourself this question
wouldn't it be better to focus on goats
1 2 & 4 that I have and do something
with them rather than chasing goat
number 3 which simply doesn't exist in
me
rule number 48 make the right choices
the man got lost in a desert and had
exhausted all the water he had carried a
couple of days ago he knew for sure that
if he didn't get some water he would
certainly die although completely
exhausted the
didn't give up hope he kept walking
looking for some sign of good fortune
suddenly he saw a small heart at some
distance could it be a mirage he thought
or maybe just a hallucination
but having no other option left he edged
closer only to realize that the heart
was real gathering the last bits of
energy left he dragged his tired body
inside the heart hoping he could find
some water the heart was empty and
seemed like it had been abandoned for
quite some time his heart skipped a beat
when he saw what was in the heart a hand
pump water finally he was overjoyed he
began working the hand pump but no water
came out he tried harder and yet harder
flow water finally after putting in
every bit of energy
he gave up out of exhaustion and
frustration and sat down thinking maybe
understand to die out of thirst today
a second ray of hope he noticed a bottle
in one corner of the hut it was filled
with water and cocked up to prevent
evaporation he uncorked the bottle and
as he was just about to devour the
life-giving water he noticed a piece of
paper attached to it the handwritten
message read used this water to start
the pump don't forget to fill the bottle
when you're done he was now in a dilemma
to follow the instruction and pour the
water into the pump or ignore it and
just drink the water what if he put the
water into the pump and it didn't work
but then maybe the instruction was
correct should he risk it if it turned
out to be false he would be throwing
away the last water he would ever see
have you ever been in a situation like
this where there are only two options
and uncertainty about which one will
work what will you do
which one will you choose well you have
to choose one and be willing to bear the
consequences that it brings many people
don't decide because they're fearful of
the consequences and they continue to
remain confused in their life the man
decided to take a leap of faith hands
trembling he poured the water into the
pump closed his eyes said a prayer and
started working to the pump he heard a
gurgling sound and water came down
gushing out
could possibly use he dragged the cool
refreshing water to his heart's content
and quenched his thirst he was going to
live feeling much better
he looked around the hut and found a
pencil and a map of the region the map
showed that he was still far away from
civilization but at least now he knew
where he was and in which direction to
go next
he filled up his flask for the journey
ahead and as per the instruction on the
note also filled up the body and puts
the cork back in and before leaving the
hut he added his own lines below the
instruction believe me it works most of
us may not be confronted with a
situation like this where the choice
made decides whether we live or die yet
we have our own journeys to take and our
own choices to make
if the choice we make goes away
fantastic we can inspire people by
telling them believe me it works and if
it doesn't go our way we can share our
mistakes our experiences our
realizations and empower people to make
choices renumber 49 find real peace
there was a king who had a great
fascination and love for paintings one
time he decided to offer a very valuable
prize to the artists who would paint a
beautiful picture depicting peace on the
final day of the judgement many artists
brought their paintings with the hope of
winning that valuable prize the King
looked at all the paintings and selected
two in particular and now he had to
choose one out of the two paintings for
the valuable prize the first painting a
beautiful calm lake with clear
transparent waters the lake was a
perfect mirror to the towering mountains
surrounding it a bow it was the blue sky
with white fluffy clouds like cotton
balls floating in space anybody who saw
this painting thought it was the perfect
masterpiece representing peace
the second painting had mountains two
rugged dry bear about these mountains an
angry sky with clouds lightning streaks
here and there
a massive downpour of rain Rochas
waterfall cascading down on one side of
his bear mountain peace thought the
people who saw this painting as the King
looked closer he saw behind the
surrounding waterfall a branch of a bush
growing out of a crack in a rock on the
branch was a mother bird who had made a
nest and within the nest is very
peacefully with great affection feeding
its little ones which one do you think
did the king choose for his valuable
prize the second one the King explained
peace does not mean to be in a place
where there's no noise there is no
trouble but there's no hard work but
there's no trials where there's no
tribulations where there's no
difficulties peace
to be in the middle of all mayhem and
chaos and yet to stay calm yet to stay
focused yet to make that inward journey
and isn't that the story of real life as
well
spirituality is the art of bringing us
to that inner calm to that inner peace
in our real life with all kinds of
difficulties troubles and problems
surrounding us that is the meaning and
definition of real peace and rule number
50 the last one before a very special
bonus clip is have fun yes absolutely
yeah
I have seen quite a few videos yes I
have I read some of his posts on
Facebook they're quite inspirational and
knowledge giving and it also creates
self awareness about lot of things which
we don't realize in day to day so it
creates a consciousness I think it's
very soothing and he gets got
information about life and all other
things logical thinking deep thoughts
the vision for a new generation I think
they're very relevant to life today and
I think he speaks for the young and for
the modern world and makes a lot of
sense he's doing a great job so I would
thank him for his contribution to
society
and ask him to continue whatever he's
doing it would be great if he could come
here and you know have some more live
talks and more interaction with people
like us he was kind of seated with his
MacBook opened and he's talking about
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
taking ahead this culture what is that
we have and properly I will try to gain
as much knowledge from him as possible
[Music]
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from guru Gopal das and how to go with
the flow that I think you're gonna
really enjoy but before that it's time
for the three point landing questions
time to move from just watching another
video to taking action in your life or
business and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go question number one what does
real peace look like for you number two
how will you prioritize mindfulness and
number three what do you need to fix in
your life first
ladies and gentlemen
isn't amazing how many plans we make and
isn't it a reality
not everything goes according to our
plots even in the game of chess we may
come completely prepared with our
strategy to win the game we may even
make our moves thinking that everything
will go according to what we had decided
and planned the reality however is once
we have made a move we have no control
over the moves that the opponent will
make we have no idea that the opponent
has also made his or her plan whether
it's the game of chess or the game of
life not everything goes according to
what we had envisioned in our lives this
is exactly why there's a great need to
go with the flow to not be rigid about
what we had decided to learn the change
our strategy as per the need of the
moment ladies and gentlemen and just the
applause
to the challenges that life throws at
you adopt new strategies to match those
of your opponent to life apply the
greatest virtue of flexibility don't be
rigid let's learn a very important
lesson from the river Ganga as she
emanates from the Himalayan mountains
with her plan to move and reach her
destination
she is not rigid she is extremely
flexible as sometimes mountains through
challenges in the form of rocks on her
path she does not stop she will either
go above them or under them around them
but she keeps moving until she reaches
her destination whatever challenge comes
on your pathway just keep moving if you
want to know what your gap all das has
to say about dealing with difficulties
and problems in your life check out the
video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there problems will come
issues will come difficulties will come
whoever you are
[Music]